dude so Goblin mode what is that I made
this video where I was on uh I was on
the subreddit confessions okay people
confessing to [ __ ] yeah one of the top
most rated ones for the last like year
or month or whatever was this one that
was like sometimes when I'm alone and
there's no one home
I act like a goblin I'll run around my
house with a trinket sack and grab [ __ ]
that I already own and be like I'll be
having that and I'll put it in my sack
and I'll make Goblin noises and so I
looked up what a goblin noise was and
anyways it's like a funny little bit and
then I posted it and all the comments
were like oh no this is like a there's a
huge sub community of people that like
acting like goblins it's called Goblin
core I didn't want to look this question
except like different yeah it was making
me really sad so I didn't want to like
actually look into it but yeah that's
why I said because it's is it not sad no
do you just go in Goblin mode I mean
yeah I guess I go Goblin mode yeah yeah
and I gobble that [ __ ] up yeah you
gobbled these nuts too